welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Avengers endgame is one way
we've been able to assemble these days
[Applause]
can become hosted Twitter watch parties
for ingame and infinity war with the
filmmakers we broke down their
highlights from infinity war now let us
review end games deleted scenes cameos
and insane reinterpretations that we
just learned about with another tweet
damn okay in the opening scene the
Russos pointed out that Joe versus
daughter Ava plays Hawkeye's daughter
Lyla
these dudes fill their movies with
family cameos and they revealed
previously unknown cameos by Joe Russo
son and his daughter his daughter's
boyfriend at the San Francisco memorial
and of course hoax fans are Joe's
daughter Leah Anthony's son Julian and
the Roosters nephew Auggie contrary to
believe Julian Russo is not the same
relative as the museum Caden stared at
cap and Winter Soldier you can tell by
the direct eye contact
next Acquia is cryptic line net it's an
earthquake under the ocean we handle it
by not handling it many have believed
this could be a nod to name war and the
writers seem to confirm that theory
saying sometimes you plant seeds
sometimes they grow and you all mocked
me for reading too much into Elizabeth
Olsen's gardening metaphors here's a
cameo by Kim Jong one of the roosters
recurring nods to their work on the
sitcom community along with a vet Nicole
Brown later in this movie they confirmed
that the book he's reading is JD
Ballard's terminal Beach a collection of
apocalyptic short stories one titled end
game the writers say they structured cap
nat and scott to go to Tony before
banner in order to give Tony time to
refuse the call to adventure
she's a critical story beat for the hero
Tony needed a moment to find Peter
Parker's photo which was behind a photo
of his dad by the way and then discover
time travel on his own in his man cave
the ruse is revealed at the location of
Tony's lake house is actually only a few
hundred yards away from the location
they used for the battle of Wakanda the
writers confirmed a deleted alternate
version of smart Hulk's intro with a
cameo by original Val Johnson overseeing
a Nakatomi tower type crisis check out
our video breaking that down there were
several alternate versions of these hime
heists their original draft didn't even
revisit the Battle of New York
originally
Wanda wasn't gonna dust and they mention
that she was gonna go on a road trip
with a rocket fun it actually mentioned
this road trip alternate version
times before it was gonna go from the
triskelion to the sanctum sanctorum
there was also an alternate Asgard
sequence where Tony Stark would have
bought Heimdall while wearing an
invisible stealth suit at will live on
in my head cannon there was also an
alternate version of Morag that would
have shown the planet while it was still
covered by ocean water with a battle
with a sea monster
instead they reshot Peter Quill's dance
from Guardians Volume one the Russos
confirm that Chris Pratt remembered all
of his moves
now the writers tried to clarify why
Natasha and Clint carpooled with Rhodey
and nebula dropping them off on Morag
first instead of the two groups
separately time jumping directly to
their planets Morag and Vermeer their
answer wasn't that clear but basically
the original sequence had fan o's
catching up to Clint and Natasha on
Vermeer we actually broke down a deleted
scene so they needed to delay Clinton
Natasha giving time for 2014 Thanos to
find good nebula and then catch up on
Vermeer but when the Boromir scene was
changed it left this plot hole in
Simpsons terms this is called a magic
xylophone I mean what are we to believe
that this is some sort of a magic
xylophone or something but folks
screenwriting structure is a fascinating
skill to learn to appreciate films in a
whole new way and it's one of the many
things you can take a class on with
Skillshare thanks to skill shape for
sponsoring this episode skill tree is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
Skillshare offers classes designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit any schedule
maybe you're feeling extra anxious right
now skills shared lets you explore
classes that may help you express what
you're feeling through creative
self-discovery taking a creative writing
or painting or Photoshop class can help
you break up the routine of a day spent
indoors they have classes and topics
that new rockstars fans will enjoy like
animation film video music production a
class I've been meaning to check out its
teach yourself to draw anything a
step-by-step process taught by a Danube
the class focuses on building a routine
of drawing so that you can prove your
skills over time my skills need some
work
I'm never gonna get that self-published
and a Morse comic off the ground I kind
of learn how to draw skill shares
curated specifically for learning there
are no ads and they're always launching
new premium classes so that you can stay
focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you and it's less than
$10 a month
with an annual subscription and the
first 1000 AI subscribers to click the
link in the description below will get a
two month free trial of premium
membership so that you can explore your
creativity
okay the writers have also pointed out
that Thanos his discovery of the time
heist was really the structural midpoint
of this movie script that's why he's so
pleased to see his future self
decapitated as Thanos understands his
destiny and the tables have turned
the amazing cap versus catfight was
Marvel stuntman Sam Hargrave who just
directed Chris Hemsworth in the movie
extraction versus his brother Daniel
also cameo Ian in this section was east
pants Matthew berry as a SHIELD agent in
the lobby and the Russos cut a really
cool shot that would have shown past and
future Tony in the same frame together
so cool writer Christopher Markus
revealed that he came out as a SHIELD
agent at Fort Lee High in 1970 and the
Russos joked that Hulk's angry bench
toss hit Frank Castle on the other side
setting up a head cannon Punisher
vengeance against Hulk so when Hulk
snaps everyone back we never see what he
saw in the soul realm like we saw with
the other people who snapped the writers
considered a dialogue between the Banner
and the Hulk identities they also
considered banner meeting natasha in
Soul realm but these along with a
Natasha funeral sequence slowed down the
movie too much over cut the knows
returns from the past the writers
confirmed that the black order was smart
enough to reverse engineer the one Pym
particle vial that they had explaining
how all of them were able to time-travel
to the present and they explained that
this Thanos was a reversal back to the
armored warlord that was in the opening
minutes of Infinity Ward the two movies
have gone full circle during this watch
party the writers also said some weird
stuff that I don't know if we should
consider Canon for example they say that
cap was not yet worthy of mil near in
age of Ultron even though most other
Marvel authorities say cap was always
worthy and was just fairing Thor's
feelings in that moment the writers also
suggest that old cap might have been
present at Peggy Carter's funeral and
Civil War which is another example the
writers continuing to refute their own
timeline logic and refuting the Russos
who interpret that caps new history took
place in a separate timeline we have
made probably a dozen videos explaining
this don't at me just watch one of those
so these statements along with their
practice gauntlet explanation for
infinity work I guess that's what we get
for asking writers too much about their
magic xylophones the hell you
the Russos were really quiet cat versus
Thanos standoff was cinematography based
on sergio leone's chilling Once Upon a
Time in the West Charles Bronson's
tight-lipped harmonica gunslinger of
bingeing Henry Fonda might have been an
inspiration for cap whispering a symbol
a chinois they also revealed that during
this battle for tonight's Donald mustard
cameo as a sorcerer probably to thank
him for that court night appearance
earlier and when cap says goodbye the
writers hinted at Bucky knew that Steve
was gonna come back suggesting a prior
chat between the two when Steve might
have cleared it with Bucky to give Sam
the shield later the writers also
explained that Sam deserves the shield
because he better exemplifies caps
idealism now as to why caps weird return
mission was left off screen caps red
skull reunion on Boromir would have
screwed up the pacing and seen the cap
return the ether to Jane Foster would
have just been too awkward for these
closing minutes and one final detail
though not visible in the final shot of
Peggy Carter's house sitting on her
chair was her iconic red hat from the
agent Carter series folks knew rock
stars in the middle of our own infinity
saga re-watch and our individual
analyses of infinity war an in-game are
in the weeks ahead so join our watch
Long's on discord by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash new rock stars
follow me on instagram on twitter ITA
vas follow new rock stars and subscribe
for breakdowns everything Marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]